for decades scientists have been digging
up dirt about the surface of mars but
what do we know about its atmosphere
now scientists have probed the upper
atmosphere of the red planet to discover
what it's made of and why mars lost most
of it to space
the martian atmosphere is rife with
carbon dioxide with smaller amounts of
nitrogen and argon
studying mars's atmosphere could reveal
the history of its climate and help
answer a vexing question was mars ever
habitable
it could also provide clues for
understanding our own planet
since 2014 nasa's maven spacecraft has
been studying mars atmosphere orbiting
the planet a whopping thousand plus
times in four years
previous probes have discovered all
sorts of things about mars's lower
atmosphere the mars reconnaissance
orbiter gauge the temperature water and
ozone concentrations
and the exomars trace gas orbiter scoped
out gases like methane which could be
evidence for biological and geological
activity
but a crucial piece of the puzzle was
missing
data from a region of the upper
atmosphere known as the thermosphere the
latest study used maven to measure wind
patterns roughly 140 to 240 kilometers
above the planet's surface
over one and a half mars years roughly
687 earth days the spacecraft repeatedly
dipped from space down into mars
thermosphere
as if using a butterfly net it captured
molecules and analyzed them with mass
spectrometry allowing scientists to
measure the wind velocities
the data showed that wind in mars's
thermosphere circulates in simpler ways
than on earth in patterns that persist
over multiple seasons
giant atmospheric waves are generated by
large variations in the height of mars's
surface far below
these results bring scientists a few
steps closer to solving the riddle of
mars upper atmosphere shedding light on
its makeup and contributing to big
objectives like the search for habitable
planets and the delivery of a complete
picture of earth's climate
just maybe that could remind people back
on earth why we look to the sky for
answers
[Music]
you